what is going on everybody welcome to
another bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
video
in this video we're going to be
discussing an extension of what we were
beginning to talk about in the previous
video and that's merchants and sales
people
with bitcoin
one of the biggest problems with bitcoin
is just pure misinformation
i keep reading the same
simply incorrect information over and
over and if you want to read you know
the new york times for your information
on bitcoin that's totally fine sort of
but if you don't research some of this
stuff you're going to be in trouble see
bitcoin's new it's a hot topic hot
button issue journalists right now are
being pushed and persuaded to write
articles on bitcoin why because it sells
there's a lot of traffic and interest
it's generating money the problem is
bitcoin is a massive field it's
constantly growing changing it's highly
technical if you're going to start
talking about it
and many journalists simply
are practicing bad journalism
so first off um
the biggest con to bitcoin that i keep
seeing thrown around by people
is that you know people wouldn't be able
to accept this as a currency or uh this
currency as a form of payment
uh because it's so widely volatile it
just would be risky
well there's not much to say about that
except for that's just kind of like
ignorance right
it may not be malicious uh but but it
that's just not the case so you enter
you know coinbase which we've kind of
brought up in the previous video so what
is coinbase if you're just now um
tuning in coinbase is an established san
francisco-based company that basically
acts as an international bank for
bitcoin if you want to think of it that
way so at the time of me making this
video there are one and a half years old
which in terms of bitcoin's world
presence is fairly timely
they have over 600 000 wallets which is
since we're using the bank account
example it's the equivalent a wallet is
the equivalent of having a bank account
so
you you can have multiple bank accounts
you can also have multiple wallets
also they they're host to over 16 000
merchants so obviously they must be
doing something that merchants are okay
with right and they work seamlessly with
the us banking system which if you
aren't new to bitcoin this is obviously
a very big deal to you
now
they have raised over 30 million dollars
for their business which is pretty nice
with a very recent 25 million investment
from andreessen horowitz sorry if i
mispronounced his name
it's that anderson horowitz vc firm
anderson is the netscape guy
so you know this isn't some sketchy
foreign no namer poor grammar website
this is a real business real ties and
real growth
so back to merchants not accepting
bitcoin because of volatility well first
why would you know why would merchants
actually like bitcoin because of based
on the bitcoin model like let's just
toss out coinbase for now but why would
merchants want that model
let's see you can't charge it back which
all merchants know getting a charge back
is pretty much a loss
sometimes you can provide shipping
information or some other stuff and you
might win the chargeback most
chargebacks are lost
so because bitcoin can't be charged back
that's a bonus for merchants
now
they're inherently with bitcoin no fees
associated um and then if you want the
transaction to go really fast you can
you can add a fee in there
and because of no flat fees
it also makes micro payments easy so
merchants can truly sell cheap goods or
cheap services
which is previously really impossible to
do so for example like me with sena or
centex i have an api where we you can um
you can run through
sample or some text to the api and then
it returns to you a sentiment value well
right now because of you know flat fees
i have to charge a
um you know like a monthly service for
this
well
uh because like for example with paypal
there's a 30 cent minimum charge on
every transaction so every transaction
would have to be 30 cents and so either
i could charge them 30 cents per x calls
but that wouldn't work because i
wouldn't make any money
or i charge like a monthly fee and say
okay here's your limit here's how many
you can call every month and that's that
but with micro payments instead what you
could do is you could literally charge
a half a penny worth of bitcoin
per
api call so this is just phenomenal and
if if this continues its growth i think
that we'll see a lot of micro payments
taking the place of advertisements
because also advertisements is sort of a
form of micro payment so you visited a
website and your page view on that
website's really worth probably a
quarter of a penny or a half a penny at
best
uh so
maybe not at best i mean if you click
the ad that's always nice
but but for the most part that's how
much your visit is worth and so a lot of
people would argue like with with
youtube for a good example
uh they'd rather pay a half a penny
or even less because it just depends on
what your your view is worth but even
sometimes it's even less than that or a
tenth of a penny to view without ads
um so so this kind of enters a whole new
market of micro payments uh in a way for
high quality content to access the
internet and that high quality content
not be degraded by ads so that's it's
pretty interesting stuff
now that's just a few things off the top
um
and i realize the ads in micropayment
isn't necessarily exactly what
everyone's worry was but it is a bonus
to any merchant
now
uh now coinbase comes in and offers
merchants the ability to accept bitcoin
but the real bonus the real reason why
this is important is that you're paid in
u.s dollars immediately
it's not like you get the bitcoin then
you need to immediately transfer it to
us dollars yourself no coinbase
literally
pays you in dollars
and but accepts the bitcoin for you so
they take the bitcoin but they pay you
in there in u.s dollars so if you're
selling something for 20
when that person sends you 20 of bitcoin
coinbase takes the bitcoin and gives you
20
so even if even if the rare chance that
as soon as they sent you or during while
they were sending you bitcoin crashed 50
it wouldn't matter you would still be
paid your 20 there's absolutely no risk
at all
now what does coinbase take obviously
they want something for this well
coinbase is going to take one percent
now uh not only is this just as safe
to accept as dollars as far as you know
what's the risk of accepting you know
dollars versus accepting bitcoins the
fee is a third of credit cards and
paypal so if you're running an online
business you're accepting credit cards
and paypal you're probably not taking
checks so and credit cards and paypal
both charge three percent usually and
then also maybe even more it's like an
average of three percent from credit
cards um but i will i'll mention that a
little bit and also i'll have a link in
the description for all of the various
fees that uh get accrued with with uh
credit cards they're horrible
uh and then like paypal charges 2.9
percent plus a flat rate of 30 cents so
that 30 cent is what kind of eradicates
micro
and um and so so coinbase will do this
for one percent so a third
and coinbase will let you do a million
dollars worth of business before taking
their one percent fee so a million
dollars worth of sales before even
adding that one percent fee so you've
really got nothing to lose by at least
attempting it
um if anything just just by purely
attempting to accept bitcoin you are
saving yourself three percent
uh that's that's that's huge so so
merchants won't accept it i mean come on
so let's see you can't charge it back so
there's no risk for the merchant there
you're paid in dollars immediately so no
risk there your bank account's tied so
no no problem there it's a legit u.s
company that's undergoing serious growth
has serious investors that we actually
know
um
i i would say uh that's the merchant
argument
and really the crux of the entire
volatility argument just shot down real
quick
since really the reason for volatility
even mattering is people say that you
can't or or stores and online merchants
couldn't accept or won't accept it due
to volatility
so
finally too the
since it kind of ties in let's just
touch on real quick why coinbase can
charge one percent and why paypal can't
right so what's stopping paypal from
being like oh man coinbase is totally
cutting our margin man we're going to
charge now 0.8
what
they literally can't see like credit
card companies in places like paypal
they pay an average themselves of 2.5
on transaction costs because moving
tracking and security or securing money
and making sure that transaction as a
legitimate transaction
uh is a very costly matter i mean just
you can probably imagine uh how hard
that would be to constantly work with
that networking required and make sure
there's no glitches and scams and hacks
and all this stuff so
they literally cannot get cheaper than
2.5
and 2.5 percent would be breaking even
so they must always charge more than 2.5
percent
bitcoin transaction costs are covered by
the bitcoin network okay so it's
basically crowdfunded by the
participants themselves who are paid for
their work simply put bitcoin is just
more efficient it's better and this is
called a free market so
even if you don't care about merchants
accepting bitcoin both this um or like
if you don't even care like if you're
not a merchant or whatever um you
hopefully can at least write people
uh when they mention this kind of stuff
because this is kind of silly there's no
nothing against it really um
so and it's just one more argument in
favor of bitcoin purely for the purpose
of also eliminating waste in society so
it really truly is just pure waste you
know um
but i will just add in though uh bitcoin
isn't necessarily
not wasteful there is another crypto
coin called i think it's peercoin
uh so bitcoin right the transaction the
reason why it's cheap is because
everyone else is doing it's the bitcoin
network that everyone's connected to so
you've got these bitcoin miners that are
using a ton of electricity so they're
not necessarily
uh environmentally friendly by any means
but peercoin
is so anyway we might we'll probably
touch on purecoin in some future videos
especially as we're comparing bitcoin to
the other cryptocurrencies but i will
just throw that out there as far as
monetary loss
uh
bitcoin
is the victor uh as far as monetary
transactions are current concern between
bitcoin and
uh
the us dollar
so and then also by the way you know if
you've ever been angry at your local
business for not accepting credit cards
uh do take a gander at the link in the
description or or even do a google
search for merchant credit card fees see
how quickly you'd get on board with that
uh so that the there's a link in the
description that just breaks down all of
the possible credit card fees i mean
it's absurd and it's somewhat
unpredictable as to which fees you might
pay per person yeah that's just pretty
crazy
so what have we learned um so far about
cryptocurrencies versus like the real
dollars right or the real dollars that's
kind of funny so let's see well the fiat
money in the world that we live on
basically as fraud and any company
committing this fraud would be thrown in
jail normally except for the banks of
course because that's what's going on
monetary transaction of dollars is very
costly and inefficient bitcoin is highly
efficient done at a third of the cost
for anybody that takes part and even um
even less if you if you don't use
coinbase right so you don't have to use
coinbase either and you could just
accept the volatility or if you buy into
the bitcoin
um
idea and market then then you wouldn't
have to even consider it
so anyway that's that if you see someone
using the volatility argument or that no
merchant is going to accept an argument
link them here so we can spread the
education hopefully stop seeing as many
journalists getting away with downright
misinformation
there's also links in the description
for the coinbase merchant information
that i've told you guys about paypal
fees credit card fees
and there's also a link for bitcoin
donation if you want
otherwise thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until the next video